- When I came out of the closet as gay,
there was almost no backlash.
Some people were kind of surprised.
I got probably what you got,
which is a lot of people said,
well, you don't seem gay,
because they want you to have taffeta
and sparkles and something,
but I didn't get a lot of anger, really.
But coming out politically,
coming out politically,
suddenly I had friends turning on me.
I didn't have any
friends that turned on me
about being gay.
If anything, it
strengthened my friendships
because we were being more honest,
or at least I was being
more honest with them.
But when I came out politically,
just saying I'm frustrated with the left,
it wasn't that I had
said I'm a conservative
or whatever you want to call it,
but suddenly I was getting a ton of hate.
I mean I'm talking about people
that were invited to my wedding,
people that I had been
lifelong friends with saying
all sorts of terrible things,
and that is kind of weird.
(mysterious music)
- Hello, I'm Douglas Murray,
and welcome to the "Don't
Burn This Book" book club.
I am here today talking
with Dave about chapter one
of "Don't Burn This Book",
which is on coming out.
First of all, Dave, I should ask you,
well, first of all,
congratulations on the book.
- Thanks.
- Second, there are two comings out
you mention in this chapter.
Maybe we could talk a
little about the first,
because I was very struck by it.
Every gay man has a coming out story,
every gay woman has a coming out story.
But it's a reminder of
how tortuous, difficult,
and in some cases, delayed,
the process of discovering
who you are can actually be.
- It's interesting because
it's one of those things,
like you, I talk for a living.
Everyone knows what I
think about everything,
but it is a part of my life
that I don't talk about
that often, and I liken being
closeted about my sexuality
to what I think many,
many people right now
are suffering from,
which is being closeted
about their political views,
and I don't meant that
in the context of some
really racist political view
or even fringe political view.
I mean people that have
views that, 10 years ago,
were very moderate and decent,
now are just simply afraid
to say what they think.
In terms of my sexuality in coming out,
it's a true story that I mention in there
that the first person
that I ever came out to
was a friend of mine who
was a stand up comic,
he was an openly gay comic.
I hate the phrase openly gay,
but he was an openly gay comic
named Mike Singer in New York City,
and I was 25 years old, so that's late.
Especially for young
people now, when they hear
oh, you didn't come out till
25, that sounds crazy to them
because they're out at 12,
or at least talking about it
as if it's not a bad
thing, something like that.
The first person I came out to,
it was September 11th,
2001, at about 12:30 a.m.
in the Times Square subway station,
so almost everyone that's watching this
can probably picture that.
It's the most famous subway
station, probably, in the world.
We were right at the shuttle train.
All the shuttle does
is go from Times Square
to Grand Central, back and forth,
so you're in this odd
sort of purgatory place.
I blurted this thing out, what I thought
was this horrific secret
that I couldn't hide anymore,
and then literally about
seven or eight hours later,
America was under attack.
I mean I woke up from a
phone call from my dad
who could see the first
tower had been hit.
He worked in New York City, he
could see it from his office.
I kid you not, I genuinely thought
it had something to do with
me releasing this evil secret
into the world, and the way I liken that
to the political part
is that it's really hard
to live one life just as a human being,
just to be who you are and
put your life out there
and find some purpose and all that,
that's very difficult in and of itself.
But if you're closeted about something,
in this case your sexuality,
or your political thoughts,
you will lie without even
realizing you're lying,
you will live more than one life.
You will have two sets of friends,
you will have family members
that don't know who you are,
all of these things.
I think people really
do understand this now
from the political side, because
I hear this all the time.
Someone will come up to me
at a college gig or something
and say, do you know
what, I'm a libertarian,
something like that,
or even the scary one,
I'm a secret conservative.
Or they'll say I'm a
closeted conservative,
and it's usually a
young person at college.
It's like if you start that
path now when you're young
not saying what you
think, it will break you
at some point down the road.
Yeah, I think a lot of gay people
just have an extra understanding of that.
- By the way, also that story you tell,
it's a horrifying story about
connecting these two events,
your personal life and then
this terrible catastrophe.
It's also sort of a
reminder to me, at any rate,
of the way in which when we
store things up like that,
we create these sort of
catastrophic ideas in our head
of what admitting what we
are, whether it's sexuality
or your opinions, your political
views, what that can do.
It means you've run through
all of these catastrophes
in your brain, and then
one has actually happened
in the real world, so of course
you've connected the two.
This is a horrifying reminder
of what this is like.
- It's interesting,
because it sounds crazy
to think that I woke up the next morning.
That sound legitimately crazy,
but it also tells you a lot
about what the closet is like.
I always say that in the closet,
there's only room for one.
When you are solo, whatever it is
that you're not telling
people that you think,
it doesn't mean you're right
about everything, by the way.
You may have all the wrong
beliefs that you're hiding,
whatever that is, but when
you are not telling people
who you are, not sharing what you are,
the only way we can figure
out what's real in life
is if we can map that
against other people.
when you say something to other people,
you express yourself in some way
and then they can say something back.
Look, you, Douglas, as a writer,
you put you thoughts out there,
and then you're gonna get a
certain amount of pushback
on some things, and then you might go,
oh, well maybe I wasn't
thinking about this
the right way, and then
you can actually change
the way you think, you can
look at things in a new way.
When you're alone and
solitary and doing that,
it affects every part of
you, which by the way,
I don't go too far into this.
There's only one chapter, actually,
that we cut in the entire
book, is when I went
really personal on some
of that struggle stuff,
and we sort of felt it was going
into another book altogether.
It will lead you down a really dark path
that I think most gay people know about.
If you're not yourself,
if you are someone else,
whoever that other person is,
you will do all sorts of
things that are not good
for the person that you truly are.
- That brings us to the other coming out
in this first chapter, and the light
that your first coming
out had on the second one.
The second coming out, of
course, is your coming out as,
well, what would you call it?
No longer of the left
or something like that.
What would you call it?
- At least at that time
that's what I thought it was.
You were one of the first
guests on my show at that point,
so this is now the fall of 2015,
and I finally started
saying what I thought,
and I was doing it from
a lefty perspective.
I was saying, hey, guys, it's our side
that's having the problem here.
Everyone can say the
conservatives are nuts
and whatever you want to say about them,
but I'm seeing a problem here.
We're the ones silencing people,
we're the ones calling everyone racist,
we're the ones not tolerating dissent
or open inquiry or any of these things.
Then suddenly I started by saying it.
This is the sort of metaphor to it.
It's like I started saying that,
and then suddenly I had Sam
Harris on the first show.
Then from that, I had Maajid Nawaz on,
who was coming from a similar perspective,
despite a very, very different
history that Maajid had.
Then I talked to you, I
talked to Ayaan Hirsi Ali,
I talked to Christina Hoff Sommers.
It goes back to what I said
about mirroring my reality
against somebody else.
Here were these people
that were extremely diverse
in where they were from
and their skin color
and sexuality and all of that stuff,
but they were feeling the same thing
about roughly what our side was.
I think from that you
start getting empowered,
because you go, whoa, I'm not alone.
There's other people who think like this.
Again, that does go very much
to when you come out
of the closet sexually
and then you meet another gay person,
and you go, whoa, they're not evil.
They're not this broken,
crushed, destroyed thing.
Then it allows you not to
think that about yourself.
I started coming out
politically in effect,
and what I didn't realize
was that there was gonna be
a whole hell of a lot of backlash to that.
I thought people were gonna be like,
oh, yeah, let's do it, and by
the way, a lot of people did.
I mean that's where it
all started bubbling up
and it sort of got me to where I am now.
But I didn't realize that.
It's like when I came
out of the closet as gay,
there was almost no backlash.
Some people were kind of surprised.
I got probably what you got,
which is a lot of people said,
well, you don't seem gay,
because they want you to have
taffeta and sparkles and something,
but I didn't get a lot of anger, really.
But coming out politically,
coming out politically,
suddenly I had friends turning on me.
I didn't have any
friends that turned on me
about being gay.
If anything, it
strengthened my friendships
because we were being more honest,
or at least I was being
more honest with them.
But when I came out politically,
just saying I'm frustrated with the left,
it wasn't that I had
said I'm a conservative
or whatever you want to call it.
But suddenly I was getting a ton of hate.
I mean I'm talking about people that were
invited to my wedding,
people that I had been
lifelong friends with saying
all sorts of terrible things.
That is kind of weird,
when you just start saying,
hey, here I am, and then people
go, well now you're evil.
- It's kind of connected, isn't it?
I'm not surprised that you said
when you came out as gay you
didn't have much pushback.
Of course there are people that do,
growing up in other areas of the country
and other parts of the world, as we know,
but I'm not surprised that you didn't have
much pushback then, but
if you had gone back
a couple of decades earlier
or several decades earlier,
you would have had a very similar thing
to what you're experiencing politically.
It seems to me that the common factor is
that in the not so distant past,
one of the objections to
having gay people around
was the sort of idea
that basically gay people
made other people gay in some
way, particularly younger men,
that somehow the proximity to a gay
was somehow catching in some way.
- That sounds right.
- Yeah, I would that it were.
But the political fact in
this is the same thing.
It's this fear that these
people who are around
who have these ideas that
aren't absolutely in lock step
with a particular dogma of the day,
other people are gonna catch it.
If we're not careful, our kids
will grow up not far left,
and then where will we be?
There's something about the toxic idea.
- Yeah, that's really interesting.
I probably, and maybe it
will be for a next book
or an essay that you'll write,
that concept really should be
extrapolated a little bit more
because I think you're right.
You come out of the closet and it's like
your friends don't
suddenly turn gay, right?
Everyone, if they're straight,
they're straight, and that's it.
I never met a friend that I came out to,
and suddenly they were
like, well, I'm gay too,
although I guess you could
have a closeted friend too
or something like that.
You're not gonna convert someone.
It's not a thing.
But you are right that when you
start coming out politically
and you start talking to people
that know more things about you.
I started talking Thomas
Sowell about economics.
I started talking to
Larry Elder about racism.
- These are dangerous people.
These are dangerous people.
- Highly dangerous people
with deeply contagious ideas.
What happens is, in that case, yes,
and that must be the real threat,
that it's not just you that they're
trying to take out at that point.
It's not just you that
they want to silence,
it's that they might go, holy cow,
some of these ideas aren't that bad.
But they have unfortunately,
and this was my frustration
with the left from the beginning,
they had become so
rigid in their thinking.
Of course, and I always say this,
I don't mean every single leftist,
but I mean broadly lefties these days.
It goes in cycles, right?
20 years ago it was John
McCain and Joe Lieberman
who were Republicans
that were trying to get
video game violence, they didn't want
mortal combat in video game stores.
So these things are cyclical for sure,
and it may eventually turn around again,
but I think you're right.
The idea is you come out
politically and you start saying
just some of the stuff that I now say.
I talk about low taxes, I
talk about state's rights,
I talk about individual rights.
Well, that stuff does spread
once people hear about it
because I think it's a much
clearer path to happiness
and a functional society,
and if you don't want that,
well, what have you got
to do to those people?
I guess you've got to
treat them as apostates,
and in effect, that's
what's happened to me
and a lot of other people.
- Deviants, that's what people are.
- Political deviants.
It's a very interesting thing.
It tells us a lot about a society.
We know it's sort of
commonplace to say it,
but you learn a huge
amount, if not everything
about a society by finding out
what is effectively taboo
or what is sort of deemed
to be socially unacceptable.
One of the oddities about
this journey you describe
of coming out as no longer on the left,
one of the oddities of it is, of course,
is that loads of people
are not on the left.
Governments keep on being
elected by majorities,
by populations who are not of the left.
One of the things that it always throws up
is how does a political
side that in many ways
has kept on losing still
have this stranglehold
that means that people
are as fearful as ever,
perhaps more fearful, of
coming out as not being
of a particular part of the leftist tribe?
- Yeah, it's super interesting.
I know you've talked
about this a bunch too,
and I go into it further
later in the book,
but I think mostly what
it is is that the left
really did the culture
game better than the right.
If you're on the right, your basic idea
is you sort of want individual rights,
and then you don't really
want the government involved,
so you don't feel this need
to be part of everything
outside of your family or
your work or your community,
something like that.
But on the left, it seems to me that
no longer on the left is
there a unifying principle.
It's very obvious that on the right,
it doesn't mean they always
hold that ideal properly,
but the ideal is individual rights.
If you're a member of a society,
you should be treated equally.
It doesn't mean we all have
the same starting point,
it doesn't mean some
of us don't work harder
or aren't luckier or a
series of other things,
but on the left, it seems to me
that there isn't a unifying principle
that brings them together, so
that leads to the hysteria.
It leads to a certain religious nature
of if you aren't exactly
what I am when I am.
It's also that you have to
change the second they change.
If the second they're for gay marriage,
everyone better be for it that day.
- Yes.
- Barack Obama ran first time
around against gay marriage,
and the progressives of
2040 will hate that man.
They will say he was a bigot
because he didn't change,
and they'll also do it retroactively
when they weren't even alive
and have any understanding
of what it was like to be alive in 2012.
But I think that thing
leads to a constant,
oh, I feel something about
something right this moment,
and that's good enough for
me to put forth to the world,
so if you don't agree
with it at that moment,
you're screwed or you're
evil or the rest of it.
Then that leaves an
awful lot of good people
just going, all right, maybe
the right isn't that terrible.
And generally what you
find, I mean you know this,
is that they're not that terrible.
- One of the other
interesting things about that,
by the way, is this
thing of excommunication.
It strikes me as being very interesting.
I mean there have been, as you know,
I wrote about this in my latest book,
in "The Madness of Crowds",
but there's this thing
of trying to excommunicate
people from the church of gay
or from being Black if they've
not got the right views
and so on, this madness
that has been going on
in recent years.
It's interesting, this
excommunication trend,
also it exists, in my
experience, pretty much solely,
in politics, on the
left, in that to be told
as you were told by people, you know,
you're not any longer of our tribe
because you've effectively apostasized.
You've broken the rules, you're out.
One of the things that always strikes me
as being interesting about
this, I may be wrong,
there may be countries where this happens,
but I've never seen this
happen on the right.
I don't know about you,
but if somebody said to me,
you know, Douglas, I don't think
you're a real conservative,
I would be like, so.
- Yeah.
- That's fine, you know.
You're not really going
to be on the right.
We are going to excommunicate you
from the right wing group.
I'd be like, who are you
or what gave you these
magical wand waving powers?
But it does happen and it does work.
This excommunication,
these magic spell words,
it works on the left.
- I think I can give you probably
the most simplest example
of what you're talking about.
Look, I make the case later in the book
for several things that
are thought of as lefty.
Let's just throw gay marriage aside.
I happen to be married to a man.
That's thought of as a
liberal or lefty thing,
so that's one.
That's an easy one.
I make a pro choice argument in this book.
That is gonna piss off
a lot of conservatives.
For most conservatives, that is the rail
you do not touch, but I
do make that argument.
I am against the death penalty.
Most conservatives are
for the death penalty.
I'm for some level of public education.
I went to the State University
of New York at Binghamton.
I believe the state does
have some role in education.
I'm for dignity with
death, that you should have
the choice at the end of your life.
I mean these are things that
are thought of as lefty,
and I have several others as well,
but I get no love from anyone
on the left about that.
Meanwhile, I can sit down with
Ben Shapiro, that scary guy,
or Glenn Beck, that scary guy,
or the scariest of all, Douglas Murray,
and we can sit down.
- Yeah, I have a couple
issues about that with you,
by the way, that you've just listed.
We'll get to that another time.
- All right, we'll have
to arm wrestle about those
next time, but that's the point.
That's the point.
Even if we had some truly intractable
political position that
we could not get over
after 10 drinks and
eight hours of doing it,
I know you wouldn't
excommunicate me at the end,
and you know I wouldn't do it to you.
If anything, I know this
Douglas, because we've done this.
We've had great political
debates, not publicly,
where we don't fully get there equally,
and that's the joy in it.
That's the joy of like, whoa, maybe,
and I say this to Shapiro all
the time about gay marriage,
where his position is
a religious position.
He's not trying to stop
my marriage anymore.
It's not that he fought for gay marriage,
and I'm very open about that,
but it's like I believe that
if Ben and I keep talking about
gay marriage, or not even
talking about gay marriage.
If the future, if Ben and
I can just remain friendly
and have conversations about politics
for the next 50 years, I
suspect that when I'm 93
and Ben is 89, or whatever it is,
he might actually come around and be like,
I guess Rubin was kind of right on that.
But there's only one way to find out.
So when you talk about
how one side purges you,
it's like how much penance
can I give these people,
if I agree with you on this,
I agree with you on this,
I agree with you on this, this, this,
and then have them just spit in my face,
while the other side, I
take some of the issues
that are most heartfelt to them.
I mean the abortion one, that is the one.
You know that, for people on the right.
And yet I take the counter position,
and I know, I mean at the
end of the abortion part,
I say now that you all
hate me, let's move on,
but I know that while they
will disagree with me,
they will not try to destroy me,
and that is just the
fundamental difference.
- Well, you know there are two
things I'll just add to that.
The first is the importance of humility
in all arguments and discussions.
Humility means that we
can keep our ears open
and keep our minds open.
The second thing that
often follows on from that
is that there is very little in the world,
certainly very little
in the world of ideas,
that is more stimulating than the moment
when you realize that you might be wrong.
Keeping yourself open to that possibility
seems to be worth doing.
I'm conscious that our time's probably up,
but we could go on all day.
- We could.
- This has been a
terrifically enjoyable book.
It gets off to a racing start.
- Thank you, thank you.
From you, that is a true compliment.
I do have to tell you something publicly
that I've said to you
privately many times.
As I was writing the book, I
had just read your last book,
and I read pretty much
anything you put out there.
The entire time, as I
was writing sentences,
I always had this thing
in the back of my head,
would Douglas Murray write this better?
Would Douglas Murray write this better?
I think I did a pretty
decent job for round one,
but let's just keep
fighting the fight, man,
and I appreciate you doing
this, so thanks a lot.
- It's a great pleasure.
See you, Dave.
(mysterious music)
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist,
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.